everything is different and new and
fresh and what drew my interest was
knowing that Chris was gonna be in the
film obviously not just because he's
attractive huge he's cute cute he's cute
his Christmas fun to be around he's a
funny guy I've never met a more generous
performer than Chris he's incredible to
work with he holds this that whole
behemoth together like a lot of us are
riding on his shoulders and what
shoulders they are he destroys the idea
of what audiences expect from him as an
actor
to have this villain s be introduced in
such a strong way is really exciting
I've had incredible fun playing with her
because I think her capabilities are so
surprising and so unusual she's not
simply sinister actually
as somebody who's played the villain in
these films I understand the
responsibilities that she has a huge
presence which she can express
physically or verbally she just has this
off-kilter movement to her character I
was completely blindsided by some of the
happiest times have been beating people
up it's been good
you